hey folks welcome to the Dark Horse
podcast live stream number
144. that's right it's number 144. I can
count with a periodicity of a week in
between who are you
who am I yes I am Dr Brett Weinstein and
I know you to be Dr Heather Hein and
this is the Dark Horse podcast and um we
are uh we're raring to go
um long time viewers will know that we
have moved and we have had to abandon
our studio and we are working on a new
studio but uh we now live on an island
where everything moves slowly so we're
getting there
um your correspondence has poured in
requesting
um that our new set have even more wood
than our last one we've done an analysis
and it turns out the only way to do that
is to use thicker pieces because it was
pretty much all wood you know that's not
going to be visible is it well they'll
know I think
the correspondence has poured in meaning
that we got one letter suggesting more
wood on the set but I thought it was a
good suggestion at the very least
you're giving me that look I just like
every everything about the story it's
fabricated that's all oh it's not fair
the idea that you look at correspondence
for instance what isn't fabricated it's
grown yeah
all right well that was that was a low
blow but you know no accurate but low
all right so here we are uh it's dark
horse live stream 144.
um
and we are streaming from this this
makeshift situation we will have a
studio again at some point but it's
going to be a little while so uh for
your viewing pleasure if you're only
listening at home
um and you want more dog uh we got dog
we got dog this time we got Madison
right here between us
uh who hopefully does not start storing
we sometimes do put her to sleep well
yeah yeah she just gets exhausted with
us okay so we will be doing a lot a q a
after this live stream will we not we we
certainly will we will that question has
now been answered you can ask questions
at darkhorsesmissions.com
you we are streaming on both YouTube and
odyssey the chat is live on Odyssey uh
you can as always find our book
everywhere books are sold 100 gathers
Guide to the 21st century you can find
merchandise at our store
darkhorsestore.org you can find
um my weekly writings at natural
selections.substack.com where I wrote
about uh vaccine mandates uh this week
and as always we want to remind you that
we are supported by you and we are
grateful to you we appreciate you
subscribing liking sharing both our full
episodes on Odyssey or YouTube or
Spotify or the clips uh at Dark Horse
podcast clips
uh at Odyssey or YouTube we even
appreciate you occasionally shaking your
fist at the screen
yeah I know we appreciate this agreement
we appreciate honest disagreement
heartfelt disagreement the the trolls
and the um well
the trolls not so appreciated yeah and
there are some whether you say so yeah
I really appreciates that
um and uh if you're in a position to do
so we of course appreciate other kinds
of support as well you can join one of
our patreons Brett had a great
conversation this morning uh with one of
his patreon groups we also have monthly
private q and A's that you can access
through mine and on either of ours you
can get access to the Dark Horse Discord
server where um a number of people from
who met on that Discord server just
completed a a camping trip an actual
Meetup and I just saw some pictures from
it it looks like it was wonderful
okay you can
also no you can't uh yeah you can yes
you can
consider uh any of the products that we
actually have as sponsors on the show
because we do not read ads for products
or services that we don't actually vouch
for
and we have three at the beginning of
the show this week as every week so
without further Ado we will proceed with
those all right and I'm up first this
week
our first wonderful sponsor is Vivo
barefoot shoes regular listeners are
well familiar with Vivo but if you're
not your feet might be in for a treat
seriously try these shoes most shoes are
made for someone's idea of feet however
vivos are made by people who know feet
and know how to use them here at
Darkhorse we love these shoes they are
Beyond comfortable the tactile feedback
from the surfaces you're walking on is
amazing they cause no pain at all
because there are no pressure points
forcing your feet into odd positions
they're fantastic the only reason that
I'm not wearing them right now is
because they are not allowed on the
couch
our feet are the products of millions of
years
the dog is the dog has persuaded us that
she must be allowed on the couch but not
in her shoes
our feet are the products of millions of
years of evolution humans evolved to
walk move and run Barefoot but modern
shoes are the overly cushioned and
strangely shaped product of a
failed design process one that has
contributed to a Health crisis in which
people move less than they might because
their feet hurt
Vivo barefoot shoes are designed wide to
provide natural stability thin to enable
you to feel more and flexible to help
you build your natural strength from the
ground up foot strength increases by 60
in a matter of months just by walking
around in them the number of people
wearing Vivo barefoots is growing once
people start wearing these shoes they
don't seem to stop Vivo Barefoot has a
great range of Footwear for kids and
adults and for every activity from
hiking to training and everyday wear
they are a certified v-corp pioneering
regenerative business principles their
Footwear is produced using sustainably
sourced natural and recycled materials
with the aim to protect the natural
world so you can run wild on it go to
Vivo barefoot.com Darkhorse to get an
exclusive 20 off additionally all new
customers get a 100 day free trial so
you can see if you love them as much as
we do that's Vivo
b-a-r-e-f-o-o-t.com slash Darkhorse
our second sponsor this week is Ned a
CBD company that stands out in a highly
saturated CBD Market
Ned was started by two friends who
discovered that their hyper modern lives
were leaving them feeling empty
bewildered and disconnected and that's a
quote something about this way of life
the quote continues just wasn't working
so they started Ned
you can buy CBD products in nearly every
coffee shop or grocery store but Ned's
Blends stand out I'm particularly fond
of their de-stress blend Ned's de-stress
blend is a one-to-one formula of CBD and
CBG made from the world's purest full
spectrum hemp and also features a
Botanical infusion of ashwagandha
cardamom and cinnamon CBG is known as
the mother of all cannabinoids because
of how effective it is at combating
anxiety and stress by inhibiting the
reuptake of Gaba the neurotransmitter
responsible for stress regulation this
combination leaves me feeling a bit
easier with whatever comes my way
many of the CBD companies out there
Source their hemp from industrial farms
in China just like with low quality
alcohol however low quality CBD can have
undesired effects Ned is USDA certified
organic all of Ned's full spectrum hemp
oil is extracted from USDA certified
organic Camp plants grown by an
independent farmer named Jonathan in
peonia Colorado
also excuse me Ned shares third-party
lab reports and information about who
forms their products and their
extraction process on their website
these products are science-backed
nature-based solutions that offer an
alternative to prescription and
over-the-counter drugs they're chock
full of Premium CBD and a full spectrum
of active cannabinoids terpenes
flavonoids and trichomes now it's full
spectrum hemp oil nourishes the body's
endocannabinoid system to offer
functional support for stress sleep
inflammation and balance if you'd like
to give net a try Dark Horse listeners
get 15 off Ned products with code
Darkhorse visit hellornad.com Darkhorse
to get access that's
h-e-l-l-o-n-ed.com slash Dark Horse to
get 15 off thank you Ned for sponsoring
the show and offering our listeners a
natural remedy for some of life's most
common health issues you know I've never
been to ashwagandha but I've always
wanted to go well now's your chance it's
right down right now no no no
to go now Ned offers you away a chance
to visit ashwagandha without leaving
your suit yeah yeah all right well
all right
um or
for those just listening our uh our
Elder Statesman cat Tesla has just
climbed into the lap of of Madison our
Labrador and they are they're sitting
together and cuddling I'm not sure how
much Maddie is into it but there it is
all right our final sponsor today is
public goods public goods is a One-Stop
shop for everyday essentials their
ingredients are carefully sourced high
quality and affordable you can simplify
your life by getting your Necessities at
public goods public goods has all the
stuff coffee and tea grains and oils
like Olive and avocado they've got
Castile soap and trash bags and laundry
detergent they have spices and extracts
vinegars and hot sauces dishware and
glassware there's so much of public
goods to make a meal including the
materials to serve it on
public goods searches the globe to find
clean healthy eco-friendly and
Innovative products public goods cares
about health and sustainability their
products are largely free of harmful
ingredients and additives and the
ingredients are ethically sourced
rather than buying from a bunch of
single product Brands public goods
members can buy all of their premium
Essentials in one place with one
beautiful simple streamlined aesthetic
and their subscription service is
efficient and simple and easy to use
public goods members can buy all of
their premium Essentials in one place it
really is an everything store
for Dark Horse listeners we have the
following offer receive 15 off your
first public goods order with no minimum
purchase they are so confident that you
will absolutely love their products and
come back again and again they're going
to give you fifteen dollars to spend on
your first pitch purchase
so go to publicgoods.com
Darkhorse or use code Darkhorse at
checkout that is
p-u-b-l-i-c-g-o-o-d-s.com forward slash
Darkhorse to receive 15 off your first
order
all right we didn't say anything at the
top of the hour but where we're going
today
where would you like to stand up that's
what oh that's later though that's not
on screen we're not we're not talking to
the podcast we're not taking the viewers
to ashwagandha are we well I don't know
I haven't seen the place it might be
worth a helmet cam and all you know okay
okay all right awesome you want to go
now
we should probably do the podcast as
long as it's on the schedule that's it
is on the schedule we got a number of
people already here yeah we don't we
don't want to disappoint
the point um
you want to have everyone's everyone's
showing up yeah okay uh do you want to
do you want to start should I start or I
think you should start okay I'm a little
distracted by all of the all of the
four-legged friends show it up what what
is the four-legged friend who's off
camera doing now
breaking into campus okay yeah sure I'm
watching TV in the cabinets watching TV
in the cabinet presumably finding my
better uh computer stand which has
somehow Gone Missing all right
Let's see we as we have said apologies
will stop apologizing at some point but
we don't have all the usual bells and
whistles and so I can't show my screen
so this is going to be a little
janky but um Zach if we're going to
start here I want you to start by
showing the screenshot of the top two
news items from nature this week so once
again nature
okay sorry Fairfax is now um playing
with a tennis ball cats don't usually do
that
um the one with the two yeah uh so
I get I get weekly emails from from
nature the one of the top two uh science
journals in the world
and nature this week has and actually if
you could possibly put us in some other
Corner that's exactly obscuring a thing
I want to be able to see
um
I can't even read it so I'm gonna have
to pull it up uh
um we could do that I suppose so in the
email that I got from nature this week
we have the top two pieces are
an editorial how nature contributed to
science's discriminatory Legacy we want
to acknowledge and learn from our
history and this is as you might imagine
uh that kind of the kind of thing that
everyone is being expected to do now I
apologize for the uh the fact that our
forebears were not moderns who
understood all of the things about
bigotry that moderns understand and the
second piece in nature this week is in
the in the basically their review of
this week's most important scientific
things that are happening and that
nature itself published
is worldview to set transgender policy
look to the evidence
policy debates concerning transgender
people are embroiled in the culture wars
let data and science not politicians
guide laws this written by someone known
as Paisley Cara
so
this piece
uh no not yet definitely not
um I have to find
I'm not totally
prepared here
this piece oh my God
the second article
just that transgender transgender policy
look to the evidence
begins
uh as follows in March the U.S state of
Utah passed a law barring transgender
girls from high school girls Sports
to find sex as quote the condition of
being male or female determined by an
individual's genetics and Anatomy at
Birth and prohibits those of quote male
sex end quote from competing against
another school and a girl's team
and this piece by again Paisley Cara
um
proceeds to
make a number of arguments that claim to
be relying on data and Science and in
this piece there is literally no
definition of sex
no purportedly scientific explanation
for how humans unique among all animals
can supposedly unique among all mammals
can supposedly change their sex
patently no understanding of the
organizational effects of hormones the
author for instance seems to believe
that hormones only work activationally
and just a you know brief
endocrinological aside here
one way of categorizing the effects of
hormones is activation versus
organizational and most hormones have
both types of effects an activational
effect is one which when exposed to the
hormone the system that is that can
respond to it and therefore the body in
which it lives the individual which it
lives responds immediately to the effect
of that hormone that is activational it
is basically the body is activated by
the exposure to the hormone then there
are organizational effects which is to
say early in development or at other
moments in development as new systems
are being laid down during development
exposure to the hormone basically sets
things in process such that once exposed
things are set in process which can
never be undone and it's these
organizational effects of things like
sex steroid hormones especially
testosterone but also of estrogens which
are widely almost universally I think
ignored and certainly ignored by the
author of this piece which gets such a
highlight position in nature this week
when they talk about whether or not you
could actually be truly truly turn into
the other sex
the fact is that if you went through
puberty as a male
you cannot undo all of that simply by
taking uh cross-sex hormones or or even
by taking puberty blockers because many
of the organizational effects of
testosterone you actually underwent in
utero and in early childhood so it
strikes me here that
um
the reality is even worse than you're
portraying it and you you hint at it
here okay
um
you cannot trying not to get out of
control you cannot have both arguments
you cannot pretend that the only impacts
are activational yes right and thereby
say well if we change your hormone
profile we've
changed you into the other sex
and also say that it is important that
people transition early right that we
cannot afford to delay uh transition
because that will have permanent impacts
on the people who
um who don't get the treatments early so
the point is if it is true and it is
true that blocking puberty uh has an
important impact than it is because
there are organizational effects which
you then cannot pretend uh have been
eliminated by some late in life
treatment that's exactly right purely
contradictory that's exactly right I
think that's that's very important and
uh just to to reiterate also the point I
made which is that the organizational
effects of testosterone do not do not
the first time that they rear their
heads is not in puberty right right that
they begin in utero with basically
beginning the process of the formulation
of primary sex characteristics and also
there's another surge of basically sex
differentiation and I think it's
toddlerhoods from somewhere around like
two to three years if I remember
correctly and I didn't go back and look
exactly so I may have that a little bit
off and then there is a period of time
in
um you know after toddlerhood but sort
of Early Childhood through what we would
think of as like Elementary School in
early middle school years uh at least as
far as schooling goes here in the U.S
where uh the sex hormones the sex
storied hormones aren't that active but
it's not that they haven't already been
so and you cannot undo organizational
effects can you mitigate the
activational effects of something by
taking that something away for sure you
can in fact possibly reverse it entirely
but testosterone estrogens and many
other hormones as well don't simply have
activation effects so the argument the
argument falls apart this in a piece
that claims
um that what it wants us to be doing is
again to look at the sub headline and
you can show us again a sec it's going
to be a little while before I ask you to
screenshot again
um
is that we he wants
I I think I think this person Paisley
yeah Paisley
I don't honestly know
um Paisley wants data and science not
politicians to guide laws well well
Paisley I got bad news for you then
because uh you can cherry pick all of
the crap articles that you want and you
did so in this piece and that does not
change the fact that sex in animals is
binary and in mammals uh you we do not
change sex and this does not this does
not belie the evidence uh the existence
of intersex people very occasionally
that's development due to developmental
anomalies nor to very very occasional
trans people who can in order to get
better alignment between their perceived
sex and their actual sex try to do
everything they can to live as the sex
that they are not but they will never be
the sex that they are not
again it's somewhat logically worse than
this because as you and I have pointed
out many times
transness exists in many cultures it is
real it is extremely rare but the fact
that it exists that it is apparently not
the product of some sort of modern
Distortion of the world means that uh
obviating the activational effects isn't
even necessary for Trans people to play
their role and live out a transitioned
life you mean the organizational effects
it either frankly but I guess my point
would be we have modern tools right we
can supplement your testosterone for
example should you want that
it is apparently not necessary to
transness what transness has been right
it is a modern uh opportunity that is
apparently not fundamental here right we
cannot fully change the uh the
organizational effects we have some
ability to mitigate the activational
effect but none of that is necessary and
certainly surgery even less so
so I I think the problem is like
um all dishonest political movements
trans activists want the benefit of part
of an argument and they want to ignore
the corollaries of it and that's right
this is just simply not how logic works
it doesn't belong in nature for one
thing yeah in in the journal Nature yeah
yeah and and of course nature who
presumably wrote the headline not
Paisley Kara
um is claiming that this is the argument
that comes from science when it's
exactly the opposite you know the claim
is don't do the politics do the science
when what the trans activists are doing
is the politics not the science right
they're doing exactly the thing that
they're screaming about you know the
tone in this paper is not screaming I
don't mean that Paisley is screaming but
there's certainly a lot of screaming in
trans activist land and uh it is it is
almost always claiming that other people
are doing the very thing that they are
doing so
for instance there's a reference there's
scant references at all or even
scientifically backed claims in this
in this world view piece
um but one piece that is cited is a
piece from 2019 called gender identity
non-discrimination laws and public
accommodations a review of evidence
regarding safety and privacy in public
restrooms locker rooms and changing
rooms well that sounds impressive
doesn't it I'm not going to go into it
here I made a bunch of snarky notes here
about the
fully crap statistics and the claims
that aren't backed up by even what they
show in the paper
but I will show this little bit of
sleazy language since I can't um can't
show my screen here quote from this
paper from 2019 has some Bush at all
critiques of anti-lgbt policies are
abounding fog Davis 2017 for example
argues for the abolishment of using sex
as a Criterion for separating facilities
let me say that again
proudly this paper is saying we are
seeing an increase in critique of
anti-lgbt policies isn't that great what
is their go-to example of an anti-lgbt
policy
using sex as a Criterion for separating
facilities
sorry no and this actually reminds me
and I don't know if we have a whole lot
that we know to say about this but of
there is a protest that happened in
Vermont today
um by an alliance that identifies as an
LGB Alliance
including people who were at the
original Stonewall riots who have been
long-term proponents of of gay rights
and increasingly now women's rights and
children's rights who see the tacking on
of the T and the Q and the pluses into
this originally movement about gay
rights as actually
not simply taking a space but actually
overturning many of the many of the
games that not just gays made but also
women have made and children as well yep
and again I mean it's uh
it is a permanent state in this style of
argument but again the idea that in one
sentence the differences between the
Sexes are so important that one must be
able to Avail themselves of
technological interventions to move from
one sex to the other in the same breath
as and isn't it uh a crime that we use
sex as a delineator for access to
facilities the point is either sex is
important and therefore it makes sense
that we would use it as a Criterion for
entering certain facilities or it isn't
important in which case what's all this
transitioning business what are you
transitioning from into right right
right yes
um yeah no the the hypocrisy and
incoherence is is Skin Deep Well it's
not even it's something else it is a
habitual desire to have part but not all
available logical argument right yeah it
is a it is a surgical separation of a
logical argument from some of its
logical consequences and that is
evidence of bad faith I mean it's just
simply is yes and this is also a
corollary we have talked about the fact
that you own the downsides of your own
arguments and this is one of these
things which is if you're going to you
know invoke sex in one sentence in order
to justify uh intervention for
transitions you can't then decry its
existence in the second right right
that's one or the other you cannot
so um
there are many things we want to talk
about today and what I want to say next
could well be understood to be a
a branch in the rabbit Warren that I
fell into and looking into this that may
not be totally warranted but I think
we're going to go here
so in Paisley's
um
a little bio
that nature
it says Paisley Cara is a professor of
political science and women's
and gender studies
oh it's actually
interesting at Brooklyn College in The
Graduate Center of the Houston City
University of New York he is the author
of sex is a sex does governing
transgender identity so since I first
looked at this a few days ago that bio
has changed that bio used to proudly
display that he is quote the founding
co-editor of the journal tsq transgender
studies quarterly
so what happens when you go to this
journal
again I can't show my screen shortly I
will ask for the second screenshot but
not quite yet
I will link to this in the show notes
trans maybe we can just slow down the
snoring a little bit here
um it's not me it's her I I believe me I
know
um
wakeful snoring is not in your skill set
no no I'm working on it you don't need
to it's super good
um transgender studies quarterly
is
described as he was just the first
sentence in about the journal over the
past two decades transgender studies has
become fertile ground for new approaches
to cultural analysis so sorry second
sentence tsq transgender studies
quarterly offers a high profile venue
for Innovative research and scholarship
that can test the objectification
objectification pathologization and
exoticization of transgender lives
okay
so what do they publish well
one of their first pieces that they
published in their very first issue is
titled
trans species
and it has the following quote not yet
um yeah more recently
Ernst Myers well-known 1942 biological
definition of species as quote actually
or potentially integrating natural
populations which are reproductively
isolated from other such groups and
quote well contested
helped solidify heterosexuality's
starring role in species debates
there are a lot of species Concepts out
there for those of us who have actually
thought carefully about what a species
is and isn't and whether or not it is a
necessary conceit or an actual thing and
reasonable people can disagree about the
answers to these questions and for those
of us who have actually also considered
many species Concepts including which
ones work best for extinct species
versus extant species asexual species
versus sexually reproducing species
plants versus animals all the things
okay yes
Ernst Meyer who
in 1942 proposed what is the most
commonly known and most commonly used uh
species concept for those do for those
trying to figure out what species are in
extant Animal Land
is about actually a potentially
interbreeding natural populations which
are reproductively isolated
has
nothing to do with solidifying
heterosexuality starring role in species
debates because what it is is actually
trying to get to a definition that is
scientifically useful so that we can do
phylogenic analysis and understand who
was more closely related to whom this
this this this movement of
I um okay go I I I I yeah I know you're
about to boil over here like I I'm gonna
sound like a teenage girl here but I I
can't even yeah I can't [ __ ] even at
this point and I haven't even gotten to
the next one yet it's even worse than
that right this is the theme for the
theme
okay the idea that what is being
centered is
heterosexuality in species definitions
no heterosexuality is Central to
reproduction that's what happened here
right the idea that there are species it
doesn't matter where you fall out on
trans activism you don't have species
without reproduction which does require
a certain amount of heterosexuality some
species are sexual well some species are
asexual fair enough and some fungus have
many many mating types etc etc etc
within animals yes
within animals which is to say for at
least the last 500 million years which
is actually smaller than animals with
invertebrates so probably for one to two
billion years we have been we are within
a lineage that it has binary Sexes and
reproduce by putting one of each
together okay with invertebrates we can
say for sure that that is uninterrupted
in our lineage there has never been a
moment in our lineage since we've been
vertebrates that we our lineage has
opted for asexuality and then gone back
or more than two never more than two in
our lineage nope didn't happen not a
possibility sorry I don't care if you
think you're a fungus you're not
um yeah so all right this journal
the um transgender studies quarterly
yeah transgender gender studies
quarterly of which uh Paisley Cara who
has a stirring role in the journal
Nature this week is a founding co-editor
yes so this is a classic case of what
years ago I called ideal laundering
right where you want to take an idea
that is nonsense
and you want to give it the veneer of
legitimacy that comes from putting it
through the
um
the trappings of scientific publication
right so there's obviously no standard
of logic here right there's nothing
these are just simply assertions that
aren't true and don't make sense that
are being dressed up as if they have
been through some sober process of
evaluation which they haven't clearly
and what's worse okay it's one thing
when that happens in
in trans gender studies quarterly
transgender studies quarterly but this
is the exact moment at which this goes
from
the friends Fringe nonsense Journal
to the premier science journal Nature
right right and not only that
it's worse than that too because the
email that you received that gave you a
little tour of important things taking
place in nature this week email from
nature email from nature juxtaposes it
with an apology for having contributed
in the past to uh racist ramblings of
people who should have known better at
least if they had been modern right
which undoubtedly there is a lot of that
in Nature's history that is uh in fact
an embarrassing fact of Science and the
fact that science is a self-correcting
process is the only thing that that
rescues it but and certainly we
shouldn't be pretending it's not right
but the point is to say we are really
sorry for screwing up the science and
allowing people's prejudices to fly uh
under a scientific Banner in our journal
and then the next headline is that
exactly and it's not as if this is
victimless right this is obviously
trampling the right of as you point out
gay people and women yes
yes so and now children because children
are being mutated permanently mutilated
right so the point is at what may be you
know the low water mark in the last
7 500 years for the journal Nature with
respect to its contributing to the
discrimination against innocent people
right it is simultaneously doing that
and apologizing it apologizing for it in
the past needlessly because we all
understand that it has taken place and
that you know History of Science
includes an awful lot of bad science and
Prejudice it's like nature is going like
we are so good at seeing what everyone
has already pointed out
and we are really bad at seeing what a
lot of people are pointing out but the
ideologues won't let us say and to have
those two things in Counterpoint with
one another in one of the world's two
premier science journals tells us that
science is in deep trouble
yes it's deep trouble this is look this
is a game of capture yeah and something
nakedly political has idea laundered in
Fringe journals and it is now captured a
premier journal and in some sense
apologizing for the past wrongs of that
journal at the same time that it is
championing new wrongs is the story
right nature is captured and frankly
we've been warning about this you
remember the uh
shut down stem campaign oh yes well
they've shut down stem that was right
after uh George Floyd died and many of
the cities in the Western World had gone
into
protests that had gone violent that had
become riots right yeah so
um clearly the thing that you need to do
at that moment is shut down stem shut
down stem and you know I don't think
people understand in general how
dependent they are on a yes admittedly
flawed but functional scientific
apparatus functional governance
apparatus functional public health
system and when these things get
captured
right yes it's all very fascinating but
worse than that it's extremely dangerous
right how for example were there to be a
global pandemic would we navigate it if
our science journals had been captured
by trans activists
right that's where we are and that's so
I got one more thing on tsq transgender
studies quarterly but that's where we go
next in fact a little bit
um
I didn't read any complete articles in
transgender studies quarterly I couldn't
I couldn't do it but I did read a number
of abstracts and I skimmed a number of
pieces
I can't say I learned anything
but here's another article that I ran
into
I'm going to have Zach put the abstract
up on the screen it's a it's called a
research article
not quite yet it's called a research
article it's from May 2017. every time
the word trans is used it has an
asterisk after it but for ease of
reading I'm going to lie the asterisk I
don't know what that's supposed to
signify
the title of this piece is called is the
title of this piece is the transness of
Blackness the Blackness of transness
and it's by someone named Marquis Bay or
maybe it's Marquis Bay I don't have any
idea now you can put up the abstract and
I will read it
yes
the asterisk in the middle of Christmas
oh yes
yes trans transasterisk dashness maybe
it is sacredness
the essay thinks the essay also not this
essay the essay
the Royal essay I guess the essay thinks
radically differently about the concepts
of black and trans trans and black thus
denote poetic para ontological forces
that are only tangentially and
ultimately arbitrarily related to bodies
said to be black or transgender that is
to say they are differently inflected
names for an an original lawlessness
that marks an escape from confinement
and a besidedness to ontology
manifesting in the modern world
differently as race and gender
fugitivity black and trans though
pointed out by bodies that identify as
black or trans precede and provide the
foundational condition for those
Fugitive identificatory demarcations
the author seeks to demonstrate the ways
in which trans is black and black is
Trans in what ways and to what extent is
there a Blackness present within
transness and vice versa
is the effect of these Analytics
this essay hopes to address these
questions but also leave them suspended
in black Trans
minality
good it's good and it's like oh my God
dare oh it's so good they're daring you
to point out that that is not
it doesn't actually even mean anything
it just it's it's it it is it is at best
bad poetry
it's folk on poetry I know it makes me
want to jump out of an airlock when I
read this but my favorite sentence I
think in this is oh they are trans and
black are differently inflected names
for an an original lawlessness that
marks an escape from confinement and a
poseidoness to ontology well I actually
kind of agree with that
I don't think it means anything but I
agree with his meaninglessness oh my God
so
the co-founding editor of this journal
of the journal in which this was
published and know the co-founding
editor of a journal is not responsible
for everything that is published in it
whereas that that line about Meyer and
about the the biological species concept
was in the opening uh volume the opening
issue so I do think that Paisley Quran
can be held responsible for that maybe
he can't be responsible for this but uh
frankly uh I would hold Paisley Corral
responsible for the whole thing because
for what reason nature did you give this
person with negative scientific
credibility a giant platform in your
esteemed but not for very much longer
publication
all right I am going to take up the
contrary position here okay
all of the shame here Belongs To Nature
I don't know what Paisley garage is I
don't know what Paisley craw is up to
okay but the entire purpose of a
scientific journal
is
to figure out what is scientific and
meritorious enough to broadcast right
to the extent that some person outside
of that world wondered
I mean effectively this is the so-called
yeah you can't folks you can't blame
Paisley for trying you can't blame
Paisley for trying to gain access to one
of the Premier science journals on Earth
and the fact is paisley he I guess has
done us a service by
revealing that that journal is uh
non-compass mentis right that that is a
legitimate service the fact is not the
service that Paisley was hoping to do
but okay I don't know maybe Paisley's
gonna reveal Paisley's self to be uh a
hoaxer who wanted to prove that the
journal Nature had fallen apart but but
the point is I don't think you can blame
Paisley for this I think you blame
nature for this no I I also put the
blame on the academics like Paisley who
have been driving Academia into the sea
for many decades now and you know the
fact that the bio uh reveals this person
I can't remember where I had it uh
as a professor of political science and
women's and gender studies
uh
and has just written sex is a sex does
governing transgender identity this
person is a political activist
masquerading as a scholar and now
masquerading as someone who knows
something about science and I I
absolutely 100 blame Paisley Cara but as
for why we are being exposed to Paisley
Cara's ideas this could have been
beneath the radar for longer if nature
hadn't decided to widely publicize this
uh this insane
anti-scientific rhetoric that is
masquerading as science well I don't
know I mean I do think this is actually
an interesting question
you have universities that will not
defend their faculty against
activists who are actively anti-science
right yeah there's something out of uh
University of Maine this week I think
uh some some some Professor insists that
there are two Sexes and one person in
the class went along with it and
everyone else had a fit and is now
demanding demanding that the professor
resign apologize Etc and there's some
Choice quote from someone who you know
saying that this is terrible and she's
traumatized and oh by the way she wants
to be a high school science teacher I
think but I have that right I think
where I come out on this is
you have to have standards to run an
institution if your institution
surrenders its standards
you know it's a little bit like leaving
the yogurt
open on the counter for a week right
I don't think it's the first that's what
that's that's what's happened to the
universities that's what's happened to
the universities they they have become
rotten because they have not
refrigerated the perishable but no
Paisley Cara is not akin to a fungus
here because the fungus pre-exists the
leaving the yogurt open on the counter
and is looking for the niche but the
niche already does exist it just may not
exist in that abundance but this leaving
the yogurt open on the counter thing
with universities has helped create the
Paisley Cross of the world of course so
it's not it's it's not I don't think
quite an afternoon I think actually the
analogy works very well because of
course the yogurt that you left out on
the counter Heather that's spoiled also
created fungus which put out spores
which made the next yogurt spoiler wait
did you just say the yogurt created
fungus well the yogurt provides a
resource on which the fungus grows which
makes the presence of fungal spores that
much more common which is very much like
the universities
but the fungus pre separately exists and
I would argue you know there's a reason
that while trans people have existed in
tiny numbers in some cultures across
time
there was a reason that we now see this
thing and people you know direct
cosplaying as the opposite sex and and
making just a mess of so much of Science
and law and University and such and it
is not because they existed all the time
and they were just looking for the right
Niche that Niche that University Niche
helped to create them I agree but and
you know of course we're not really
talking about trans people we're talking
about trans activists who have taken
over the universities yeah and the point
is yes there's something a little bit
different than the biological case in
the sense that the fungi that attacked
the yogurt are very long-standing in
some sense but there's nothing unique
about the idea that the yogurt provides
a different environment than whatever it
is the fungus Road into the house on and
that it will adapt to the phone if you
keep leaving yogurt out it will become
very well adapted to gaining access and
exploiting yogurt and that is it that is
what happened to the university the
university did not guard itself against
terrible anti-scientific
anti-enlightenment ideas those ideas
flourished and experimented there and
they have now proliferated out into
society where they're looking for all
kinds of things Beyond yogurt that they
can spoil
I mean I just think it's almost it's
almost it's a Perfect Analogy in my
opinion and the point really is just as
I don't blame a mosquito for sucking my
blood right I might blame somebody for
leaving the door open if that's how it
got into the house or something but I
don't blame the mosquito mosquito is
simply doing what mosquitoes do people
gaming systems is what people do and it
is the obligation of the people who are
stewarding those systems to protect them
from this nonsense yes but unlike unlike
a mosquito which cannot receive
education and be taught to eat something
else how do you know a human being who
truly believes that they are preaching
in science when they are preaching
anti-science and actually doing damage
to not just a lot of people but a lot of
functional systems is at base a human
being who can unlearn the garbage that
was facilitated by the university system
okay I I agree with you I'm not look my
expectation is this person who has gamed
uh this system
probably their intent on
they are at least deaf to the damage
that is done by what they're up to right
they're putting us all in danger by
doing this but I guess what what I'm
really getting at is
if you have a government you should
absolutely expect people to try to
corrupt it right to the extent that you
just assume that away and you leave it
vulnerable to corruption it will be
corrupted and I don't necessarily expect
the people buying influence
uh to you know rain themselves in never
that's not how it works you leave yogurt
on the counter it's going to spoil you
leave your government open to being
corrupted it will be bought and
purchased by people who you know see the
opportunity early
right if you have a university that is
supposed to be studying truth and you
leave it open to threats from powerful
political groups they will take over the
truth apparatus you have a journal that
is supposed to uh limit uh itself to
only high quality ideas in circulation
and you know you haven't provided a
mechanism whereby it will turn down
political fads then it will be taken
over by political Fed so
I guess the point is I these are
entities filling niches and I don't I
think the point is the game is always
won or Lost based on whether or not you
left the niche open if the niche is left
open expect it to be inhabited it may be
inhabited by this person or that person
it may be inhabited by this fungus or
that fungus but the the real story is
you left the niche open not something
inhabited that neck
I think they're both a story
and um
at the
how do we change this and how do we
create systems that ensure that they
don't get gamed what you're talking
about is the play is the only place to
focus we don't focus on the perpetrators
of you know the people who are making
bank whatever that might mean on
um gaming the current system that
doesn't mean that they don't have agency
and don't have Consciousness and
couldn't actually be be better human
beings if they were trying yeah okay I
think we've now arrived at it the real
point is there's only one game in town
from the point of view of preventing
this sort of thing however it doesn't
relieve anyone of responsibility for uh
yeah being bad and externalizing harm on
others or exploiting uh illegitimate
niches yeah
okay uh I got a couple more things let
me do one of them and then maybe you go
and then we'll see if we have time for
my final thing
this week
the Washington so I don't have any
screenshots for you on this one
unfortunately Zach I will link to
everything here but I can't show you
this week the Washington Post published
an article headlined women said
coronavirus shots affect periods new
study shows they're right
sub headline a coronavirus vaccination
contains the timing of when you get your
period according to research for most
people the effect was temporary
my first reaction to this was and I
apologize some of you don't like it when
I swear and some of you like it a lot
when I swear but you don't [ __ ] say
Guapo like yes we know and yes there are
a lot of us who were yelled at and told
that we were anti-vaxxers and far worse
for suggesting that people were actually
experiencing real effects from an
experimental treatment so yeah
good on you you're a little bit late
you're actually a lot bit late so
there's a news release on the study from
NIH which goes into a little bit more
detail and then of course there's
original research which I'm going to
read you a few things from uh it's an
Edelman and all paper and um
uh bmj medicine called association
between menstrual cycle length and
covid-19 vaccination Global
retrospective cohort study of
prospectively collected data
[Music]
so
I guess let's do it this way
[Music]
we wanted to no no I need a pen this one
doesn't work
um
the yeah let's do it this way I'm going
to read you a couple paragraphs from the
wapo piece The Washington Post piece
Allison Edelman a professor of
Obstetrics and Gynecology Oregon Health
and Science University based in our
former hometown of Portland Oregon
Allison Edelman who led the study said
that for most people the effects were
temporary lasting for one cycle before
returning to normal she said there were
no indications that the period side
effects had any impact on fertility
now we can give people information about
possibly what to expect with menstrual
cycles Edelman said so I hope that's
overall really reassuring to individuals
well no actually it's not and here's
part of why
um the study this is literally from the
abstract of the study analyze data on
quote at least three consecutive Cycles
before vaccination and at least one
cycle after
one
one cycle after vaccination and they
looked at a lot of people you know they
studied a lot of women
sorry it was all women but
the idea that you can tell anything
about long-term effects
um or impact on fertility on the basis
of a study that looked at
least but actually usually exactly three
Cycles before and one cycle after
vaccination
on what basis is she making these claims
and those claims that she's making is
the lead author on this study are now
going to be the ones that are repeated
and now are going to be the basis for
the you know PolitiFact and the fact
Checker organizations who come after
People Like Us who say actually no that
research can't say anything about
long-term effects or effects on
fertility it simply can't did you read
the study
and the fact is the fact Checkers at
these places aren't scientists they have
no ability and apparently interest in
actually reading the research on which
they are supposedly fact-checking and
here we have the lead author on the
paper making egregiously misleading and
frankly just flat out wrong statements
to Washington Post which of course is
going to be the thing that people see
well and
that quote the idea that upon
discovering that indeed these effects
that many of us have talked about are
real that the proper response to that is
for people to be reassured rather than
for the safety apparatus to become
alarmed and say well all right given
that these effects are real and they
shouldn't be happening because these
things aren't supposed to be showing up
in your reproductive apparatus at all
yeah right so these that there's any
signal at all here is a story right it
is a story and the right response is how
does that change the cost benefit
analysis for any individual who might be
taking these things the answer is not oh
well in our study it turned out to be
short term because that's all we studied
right and therefore people should be
reassured I hope this will cause people
to be reassured there is nothing what
are you are you a scientist or are you
in fact someone who's just trying to
change people's minds right the point is
this is this is the sound of the
scientific apparatus being used to
rationalize irrational and dangerous
Behavior right you've got a safety
signal here and the response is oh
it isn't the safety signal is no worse
than could be found in our short-term
study therefore people it it's the
absence of evidence is no is not
evidence of absence right there is no
long-term aspect of the study published
here and so the point is they're saying
well there's no evidence of a long-term
effect well it wasn't a long-term study
here we have actually in the paper
conclusions conclusions of the as
written into the abstract quote covid-19
vaccination is associated with a small
and likely to be temporary change in
menstrual cycle length but no change in
mensy's length likely to be on the basis
of nothing in the paper that has no
place in this paper at all in the
abstract in the conclusions anywhere
where did that likely to be come from
because they want it to be that is Hope
pretending to be science and that hope
then lives in apparently the lead
authors had sufficient that she says to
The Washington Post when they come to
her she she repeats the hope as if it is
the science guess what hope isn't the
same as science this is not how science
works
so either this is a case of
pharmaceutical idea laundering right
where they take a pharmaceutical uh
talking point and they launder it
through a scientific process so that it
appears to be scientific in some way or
this person actually believes they've
engaged in science themselves and it is
a case of some kind of brain laundering
right that their mind I don't see any
reason like the paper it's the research
that was done yeah if you ignore the
editorializing in the text of the paper
itself and certainly the editorializing
that is happening extra paper like
outside of the paper the the actual
design of the experiment seems to be
like this the science in so far as it
said something narrow and true seems
fine so I don't I don't think we want to
say oh yeah was she even doing science
like no no no no no no I don't agree
with that because it'd be one thing if
the people who did the study had done
the study legitimately and then someone
else scientific was commenting on it
with this sort of absurd conclusion but
if it's in the paper itself right then
the point is the paper is a is a
scientific process the scientific method
may be narrowly applied to the
experiment that was done but the
extrapolating only so far as the
evidence allows you to right right but I
didn't say this paper is a good example
of scientific research I said I think
that from what I can see the actual
research that was done although it is
not accurately portrayed in this paper
was potentially good that is what I said
well
I
I don't see it that way because
the degree of extrapolation is inherent
to the scientific process and so if that
part is bad that leaves you suspect as
to what else happened that isn't visible
in what we can see no I would just say
first of all if you were to go back
through every
terrible wrong paper and say well the
work itself
does was this a valid experiment right
you would find many valid experiments
that just didn't establish the thing
that the paper claimed they'd
established so yeah I'm saying to the
extent that you have presented a piece
of work and the piece of work is
here's the data we collected and here's
what it implies based on the fact that
we had or did not have a pre-existing
hypothesis and these are the things that
showed up
Etc right the point is you either did
that job writer you didn't and to the
extent that you ran an experiment that
might be valid embedded in some paper
but not the paper you wrote that's a
pretty thin defense okay
um
one more thing on this story
back to the Washington Post piece
later in the same article I'll just read
these two short paragraphs
other research has suggested that the
vaccines against the code vaccines have
a variety of effects on periods a survey
published last fall collected
information about periods and vaccines
from 160 000 people including
transgender and post-menopausal people
and found that thousands reported
heavier bleeding than usual or
breakthrough bleeding
while these observations aren't
necessarily medically alarming Catherine
Lee an assistant professor at Tulane
University who led the survey said the
information is important to help trans
men plan for additional support if
menstruating causes gender dysphoria and
also to help people make decisions about
stocking up on tampons and pads
so the first mainstream media
acknowledgment that all those women who
were saying that their periods were
affected by the coveted vaccines and who
are now worried about fertility issues
and such and frankly no one has done
anything to allay those concerns the
first mainstream media article to talk
about this at all somehow manages to
talk about trans men
but what is going on here how how are we
constantly coming back to a fringe
activist population when there is
actually half of the world who is at
risk from these experimental treatments
and here we are being concerned about
gender dysphoria and trans men and what
is going on it's it's worse than that
because
because it's got to be the title of this
episode it's worse than that they have
created the entire problem if you simply
didn't [ __ ] up the definition of women
then those women who happen to be trans
men would be covered by this without
having to specifically say anything
right the point is
there is something called a woman right
it has a biological definition that
isn't difficult it allows you to
extrapolate from a paper without a
problem and the only reason that there
is any argument for breaking out trans
men as victims of this is that you you
scuttled that definition for your own
political purposes it it's frankly
insane
and maybe that's the point it's more
it's more it's insane and this and this
is more
again of
the
there are a lot of sex-specific effects
of covid and the vaccines right we know
this the myoin pericarditis
uh that has been finally begun to be
acknowledged uh that is uh more of a
risk for young people is specifically
more of a risk for young men
for adolescent boys and young men
and uh early on we were hearing uh and I
actually just haven't seen the stats
recently but I assume it's still true
that
um all else being equal covet is more
likely to go bad for you if you're male
than if you're female if you know
controlling for all of the other
demographic truths about yourself
and so here we have one of the places
and you know of course there are all
those insane papers uh insane articles
early on about how even though men were
dying more code was harder on women
remember this
wow you're really really working hard
there well darling it's only hard on you
at first but here's what you've done it
it becomes it's all downhill yeah now
they now they're lazy again right those
men not doing their work not doing their
fair share of cleanup after they die
um but now we have fertility effects and
you know I don't know there may be
fertility effects for men too I haven't
we haven't been hearing about those
um so much but there have been Lots
there has been lots of talk about uh
menstrual effects which of course has
the potential to have to be a fertility
effect in women and here we have some
research that may or may not actually be
you know bold enough to have actually
seen this and the Washington Post can't
even talk about women for one article
it it it has to go into trans activism
sophistry ideology
it we're not we're not allowed to just
talk about fertility effects for women
even though that would fully include
trans men yeah you didn't you didn't
need you didn't do that damn thing they
were fully included in that discussion
if you just simply didn't do a thing but
but no
yeah
it has to be the focus it has to be the
focus all right
um
maybe I should take a break all right
you you calm down a little bit
um
yeah
I noticed this week
um that apparently and I I admit I don't
know exactly who's eligible yet but
amongst people who are eligible for
these new bivalent boosters the Pfizer's
new yep yeah uptake has been
extremely low and my feeling is you know
whether you love Pfizer or hate Pfizer I
think we can all agree that no one has
done more to help covid than the people
advisor so I wanted to return the favor
and suggest that actually what they've
got is a marketing problem
and I'm not looking I'm not going to
charge them for this service but I
thought I would give them a little
advice on how to redirect their
marketing campaign for these bivalent
boosters so that they would get more
uptake awesome so you're going into
marketing you're going to pro bono
marketing I just it's not the career
move I was expecting they're not seeing
the big picture they're not seeing the
big picture that's how I heard that Nazi
ain't no I that was an unintentional if
poignant pun indeed um but in any case
uh my thought was this so far they have
marketed these
so-called vaccines on the basis that it
has some yes waving your arms and
obscuring lots of facts about
transmission and contraction of the
disease which it doesn't really prevent
and all that but they've sold them on
the basis that something something
something positive for your health or
something along that lines oh and save
grandma and be a good citizen yeah all
those sorts of things and it's not
working so I think they've just got it
wrong and what they should be doing in
light of the let's say
unprecedented safety signal that has
shown up in the vares system and the
military database they should be
marketing these things as uh
inoculations for Daredevils and the
thrill sequence right and I just think
it would be more successful right it's a
it's more honest right the you know the
question is it's kind of a Gamble and
um that if they were upfront about that
it might be be that people you know
started lining up for these things and I
wanted to suggest stay on tight we're
going to take you on a ride yeah that's
a little wordy that's a little I was
thinking something more like
let us hold your beer
oh right right or uh
um how about this one
what are you chicken
and you could even with that one you
could have noises right sure sort of
goating people into demonstrating their
bravado you know you have to make a page
out of Red Bull's Playbook oh yeah right
also uh it occurred to me that you know
they could just go
straight at it
CH myocarditis right
the Daredevil just
scoffs at my otherness they don't fear
it yeah I don't think that one works as
well because that sounds like you don't
believe it exists rather than I'm not
afraid of a little myocard properly used
why aren't myocarditis suggests you
think it's unimportant whether you think
it's not for real right so anyway
I mean I think this is this this is the
way to go you know just before your next
adventure
do a pre-adventure
do a free adventure yeah all right well
that was more or less the idea that's it
that's it I like it that's that's that's
great
that's great okay
um
let's see
I uh I find myself a little bit thrown
by not being able to show my screen here
we go okay one more one more story
um
Phil Harper
who's awesome you've met him I haven't
um he's got a sub stack the Digger which
I highly recommend I will put on in the
show notes he pointed to a talk but
somehow I can't now find the talk so I'm
gonna just point to his sub stack
generally
um but so just hat tip to to Phil Harper
here because I wouldn't have known about
this talk but for but for him
um and unless I dreamed the whole thing
in which case I don't know where how I
come into finding this talk but uh
there's a talk given at Oxford in March
2022 in which a Dr Dame June rain who is
speaking on behalf of the regulatory
agency in Great Britain known as the
mhra that's the medical and Healthcare
products regulatory agency
the tagline for which is regulating
medicines and medical devices so it's
basically if you're American that sounds
like the FDA the analog to the FDA she
gives a talk about the mhra about the
medical and Healthcare products
regulatory agency
which remarkably she calls from Watchdog
to enabler
regulation and covet and after so I've
got five screenshots from the talk
um
so uh and again I'll link to the talk in
the show notes as well associated with
this screenshot with her introducing her
talk here she says
I'm going to talk about how the coveted
quote how the coveted pandemic has
catalyzed the transformation of a
regulator from a watchdog to an enabler
and I was telling you about this Brett
that you were like enabler of what like
of the Pfizer of the pharmaceutical
companies she's mostly talking about the
Pfizer shots in this talk but she also
goes into talking about AstraZeneca a
little bit but almost entirely she is
talking about being proud to have moved
a regulatory agency from being have
understanding its role as that of
watchdog
to that of being an enabler of the
developers of the treatments that are
being brought to them in this case the
Pfizer bioin Tech vaccine it's a classic
case of saying the quiet part out loud
it
unbelievable it's a jaw-dropping I
recommend this it's you know it's 25
minutes or so and you can skim parts of
it it's you know sort of standard
academic conferency stuff
um the next and just a few screenshots
here next screenshot Zach uh here we
have on the screen a couple of little
speech bubbles and
what she says associated with this is so
I was dashing into number 10 for a
meeting in the cabinet office
right so she's you know she's important
enough to be that's number 10 Downing
Street of course um that's like sayings
I was dashing into the White House for
meeting at the cabinet office if she was
American and in that meeting in that
meeting at number 10 in the cabinet
office she is asked as it shows on
screen
by someone I didn't catch the name uh
will the mhra stop us from killing
people
and she immediately responded no the Mr
HRA will help you keep people alive
and this is how she understands her role
changing as a regulator as as a person
who's helping lead a regulatory agency
through an emergency is no I'm not going
to put the brakes on I'm gonna speed
things up
so again proud enough of this to have it
on screen okay next screenshot
uh this is just this is not all that
informative this has the tagline for
mhra but what accompanies are saying
this uh what a company what accompanies
her showing these agencies that are
collaborating now under under her
watchful guidance is quote we
collaborated across these boundaries as
never before and she does say she knows
we need to remain independent that's
really important but then she says
enthusiastically that quote we tore up
the rule book
but during covet we the regulatory
agency in of Great Britain tore up the
rule book
okay next screenshot
so this
shows uh the mhra having facilitated
chain having allowed Pharma Pharma to
change the timing of clinical trials
whereas used to be phase one phase two
phase three had phase one had to
actually be done before he went into
phase two and phase two had to be done
before you went to phase three
um she she is proud of the fact that
during covet under mhra they changed the
guidelines so that now pharmaceutical
companies could modify the timing of the
clinical trial such that you could have
the phases overlapping one another and
she says quote of the vaccines
which had begun to be manufactured well
before even the first phase was done
first phase of the clinical trial was
done quote large-scale manufacture was
prepared at risk we did not know if any
of these vaccines would be effective end
quote but surely surely everyone even
this audience that this small audience
where she's giving this talk at Oxford
in March of 2022 can see that at the
point that the government has purchased
in advance the large-scale manufacturer
of a whole bunch of vaccines and they
don't actually have the safety data yet
but it's going to be that much harder
to say actually no all of those have to
go into the trash
hate to say it but it's worse than that
it is because if you if you listen to
this knowing what has taken place during
this process right if you know what we
know now about what took place in the
drug trials for example
there was never any risk that these
vaccines were not going to be safe and
effective right
so in which case why not do this right
like why not just overlap phase one
phase two that's just the thing this is
pro forma the idea is what we now have
is a safety system incapable of
recognizing a safety signal that is
really just a a laundering a safety and
Effectiveness laundering apparatus for
that is
um effectively a branch of Pharma and if
that sounds hyperbolic no I know in the
U.S that a tremendous percentage of the
money that flows through the regulatory
apparatus is actually Pharma money right
that the system has been built to fail
where the controls have been handed to
Pharma the financial controls the power
of the purse effectively and
what
what this sounds like to me
if you were if you've got if you're a
Pharma then you ought to live in fear
that the regulatory apparatus is going
to be
uncompelled that your product is safe
and or effective that's what they're
there for and really if you're a Pharma
you ought not live in fear because you
ought to know the regulatory apparatus
is there and therefore you ought to do
your damn job and produce a safe and
effective product to begin with right
but of course uh the fiduciary
responsibility of the corporation is uh
clear and the fact is it was very
expedient from the point of view of
taking care of their shareholders to
capture the apparatus so there was never
any risk right that at a business level
that makes sense it's criminal but
um at a business level it makes sense
and so if you were to do that if there
is a governmental regulatory apparatus
its purpose is to prevent dangerous and
or ineffective treatments for making it
to Market Pharma can't tolerate that
because
business is difficult so it captures
that apparatus it's still the zombies
inside of that apparatus still exist
they still have to give speeches about
their role in the process they have to
occasionally wag their finger at Pharma
in order that they still look like a
regulatory apparatus but basically what
will they sound like to themselves right
they will sound like they think it is
clever that they tore up the rule book
right they will be proud of the fact
that their Watchdog role has been
transformed into enabler which surely is
not the term she was looking for
facilitator it was literally in the
title of the talk right so the point is
to the extent that people talk behind
closed doors and they say things that
they wouldn't and shouldn't in public
this is one of these cases where enabler
sounds like internal language it sounds
like frankly Pharma language right we're
right actually we're gonna get the
regulatory apparatus to function as an
enabler of this process well maybe she's
the Rochelle volinsky of that is exactly
what I'm getting is let's put it this
way
what Pharma did is Despicable but it
makes sense right what these people do
is Despicable but it makes sense right
these are careers that are being made
how is your career being made is it
being made by being a good Watchdog no
that'll get you tossed out on your ear
right it's being made by transitioning
Your Role from Watchdog to enabler right
that's how you rise and so the point is
we are hearing this weird mixture of the
internal dialogue and the Public
Presentation of you know the Victory lap
and it's like well hey what are you
taking a Victory lap about it's not like
you distributed a product that worked
right it didn't and what's more it was
hugely dangerous so why you know why are
you championing the change in the
process that you you shepherded but
nonetheless we get to hear it and it
does sound like
um
it sounds like what you would imagine a
captured regulatory industry uh
apparatus is like on the inside yeah
right as it rationalizes to itself it's
failure totally and actually the the
last screenshot which isn't a it isn't a
giant deal but uh I'm gonna show it Zack
uh proudly discusses the agency's
regulatory flexibilities
and you know that that like enabler
strikes me as a word that they really
had and not publicized they they are as
you say saying the quiet part out loud
here and yet you know as easy as they're
making it for those of us who are paying
attention
still
still we are the ones who are considered
to be purveyors of Miss dis smell and
all the other bad types of information
yes which of course have been declared
terrorism
yes I don't know if they have them Great
Britain or not but well I mean Great
Britain is one of the five eyes no doubt
terrorism here is Terrorism there that's
probably true so yeah yeah
so that um that happened back in March
2022
um and uh
it's shocking frankly I I I'm no less
shocked than if
then if the FDA I don't even know who
the lead on the FDA is but some
equivalent person at the FDA to
this woman at the at the fda's analog in
in Great Britain
had said these things we are proudly
moving we're excited we are excited to
have thrown away the rule book
to have moved from Watchdog capacity to
enabler to be engaging in regulatory
flexibilities
and and anyone is confused as to the
lack of oversight
and the fact that we don't actually lots
and lots of people ever more every day
are saying I don't actually trust you
guys to make decisions on my behalf
not you not now yeah well the um
one of the truly evil aspects of this is
that many of us were calling attention
to the evidence of what was going on as
it happened and the evidence was of
course less than it is now right right
but that was a very risky thing to do
right and
um we can now see
that you know
what should be a
alarm Bell going off at the
acknowledgment that in fact there are
reproductive consequences to these
products
um and that that ought to cause a
rethink probably temporary probably
temporary right but the point is you
what you can see for sure now with the
amount of evidence that is currently
available even just to the General
Public
what you can see is that the system is
completely indifferent to the risk it's
putting citizens to happen completely
indifferent it is not changing its tune
about whether or not you should be
inoculated with this stuff based on the
alarming evidence of the safety signal
based on the evidence of the
ineffectiveness of the shots at
preventing you from Contracting or
transmitting the disease because you
have to do any attempt at risk
stratification analysis no evidence of
risk stratification which tells you
right there that this process has
nothing to do with health because the
cost-benefit analysis is obviously risk
stratified which is just to say again
like Risk stratification by age and this
is something we've talked about before
in many many doctors have as well we
have known from the beginning
that this virus is much more likely to
bring you to your knees the older you
are also the more comorbidities but the
risk stratification by age means that
given that the virus is very unlikely to
do you harm if you are a healthy young
person and also separately the vaccines
seem to be more likely to do you harm
the younger you are wrist stratification
analysis would suggest that there should
be different guidelines for at the very
least different guidelines for whether
or not you're expected to take this
thing steeply different steeply
different and yet what most the elite
universities in the United States are
now requiring not just vaccines but
boosters for their students for their
presumably young healthy student
populations are you trying to kill them
what is going on right it's insane you
should have let's put it this way the
date if there is an argument for these
so-called vaccines at all
there should be an age at which the cost
benefit analysis flips enough in their
favor that we recommend it and that age
should be in motion with more evidence
that we have and the fact that that age
doesn't exist at all we're just like oh
they're good get them yeah right that's
like six months old get them pregnant
get it right yeah that's that is a
manufacturer's view of a product is this
product for you definitely yes right
there is no it's not a question well who
are you let's figure out whether this
product is for you you can see that and
so as long as you're human we got a
thing for you as long as you can see
that that is what's going on that the
thing is not interested in who you are
even though the evidence suggests that
that should be the primary question in
deciding whether or not to recommend it
and that it isn't just the manufacturers
who are so indifferent to your
well-being it's the thing that is
supposed to be protecting you once
you've seen that then the real question
is well was that true from the start
what about all that [ __ ] you told me
that turned out it wasn't right did you
know it wasn't right right right that's
really the question and
um I do hope we ultimately I I doubt we
will ever get a full Reckoning but we
have to we have to try because
um to the extent that the system
that allowed this to happen is
completely captured and we are dependent
on its functioning not just this time
but next time
it won't be better next time unless we
figure out what got into it that's right
no and one of one of the
um recurring themes in that video that I
showed you screenshots of from Oxford in
March of 2022
is the is the rejoicing that during the
next pandemic and there will be a next
one she proclaims and it's true
they've already got all these changes in
place so it'll be easier next time it'll
be easier next time to be the enabler
and no worries about them being a
watchdog
s
be time for us to get off all right
oh damn it you do have water over there
it's not helping I could get okay
all right
well oh my God you're all right
talk I'm trying to figure out how to
address the conclusion of the podcast
you're back
all right
oh dust ah it's still there okay let's
let's finish this up yep can we
um
we'll be back for Q a
whenever I stop coughing
approximately 10 to 15 minutes that's
right
that's
right
all right you can ask questions at
darkhorsesmissions.com
you can email logistical questions I
went to Dark Horse moderator gmail.com
if this happens again I'm just going to
start singing please do something don't
just look at me while we're stuck to one
camera's camera here oh my god
um
okay so uh join our patreons
Brett has an you have another
conversation tomorrow right yes I do for
one of your patreon groups yes sir those
are always good
uh if you want to read a little bit more
about objection to vaccine mandates and
why they are out of control go to my
substag Natural Selections that's what I
wrote about this week
and uh and we'll be talking about that
more on Dark Horse soon as well I think
uh and until next time we'll be back
here uh same time next week until then
be good to the ones you love eat good
food and get outside fly low and avoid
the Dust
foreign
[Music]
[Music]